A runaway
puller, Ally
, there's no point if he's along
We're not enemies
, let's apologize to the meat I'm sure we'll
get along better than before It's
rare for us to talk about the same things we like
I
love you, I know,
but yeah, I really like my family
Why did you come to this place
?
That's what I like now
Let everyone who was hiding there
know  I'm not stupid enough to attack even though I have no chance of winning like that
That's stupid
And
Gutaro isn't as dull as he thinks
So thank you for the Yotsuba version
I wondered what would happen at one
point
Oops  This is
Itsuki
Thank you I'm sorry Minu It's
okay Mizukusa-san
Thank you and when will you go